how does the hero's journey apply to
storytelling well the hero's journey
applies to storytelling because it is
storytelling you know it's it's uh the
way that we have been programmed I would
say to understand what a story is and
this is a a difficult question to say is
this something that we have learned uh
socially because we've seen so many
stories that we have formed an idea that
every story more or less follows this
journey pattern or is it something that
is deeper than that that's hardwired
into the human nervous system and that's
kind of where I go it certainly
reinforced by seeing thousands of
examples but I think that we would
recognize the hero's journey and respond
to it in the organs of our bodies even
if if we weren't acculturated to it even
if we didn't have the many examples we
would recognize it and respond to it and
and this again goes back to the stick
figure idea if you just draw stick
figures uh if they have any kind of
Desire or wish whether it's I've got a
knife and I'm going to stab this guy or
I want to give some of my food to a
starving bird
we get on board and we want what they
want or we're watchful will they do this
terrible thing or will they do this good
thing and we just can't help but be
involved so that tells me I think that
uh that the the hero's journey is uh
sort of the internal wiring diagram we
have about stories and that it's
something very very deep
is the hero's journey of formulaic
blueprint for writing a screenplay well
the question comes up
um what do you call this thing the
hero's journey is it a formula is it a
pattern is it a mode is it a paradigm I
mean there are many words that have been
applied to it
um
I think the word that's being used a lot
these days to describe other things as
algorithm and I think that's one good
way to look at it that you know an
algorithm is a sort of a numerical way
of uh analyzing things and
planning how things will progress in a
system
but I think the hero's journey is is
something like that
I don't think formula is a good name for
it because that implies that it's like a
cookbook recipe and that anybody who
puts it up there is saying well you have
to do this and you have to do that in
this sequence and this then this can
only be the next thing and this can only
be the thing after that and
um I very strongly
discourage that
my point of view I guess has come around
to the idea that you must know this form
and it is a form that exists and people
know it and they recognize it
um
but you are obligated as an artist to
break that form every single time you
set out every time you write a song or
make a dance or create a story
um it's part of your obligation as an
artist to defy my expectations and
surprise me with something a combination
or leaving an element out that I've
never seen before
I'm thinking about the mentors that I
mentioned before and a kind of shocking
thing to me was a movie called Amur like
the French word for Love by a director
Michael hanaki and uh this won an
Academy Award for best foreign film some
years ago and it's a story about
an older couple
who are sort of part of the music
Intelligentsia in France and the wife is
declining with some form of dementia
Alzheimer's and the husband is dealing
with it and he keeps turning to what
would be in a normal story a mentor he
goes to the doctor he goes to his
daughter he goes to various nurses and
people who are there to help take care
and none of them has a clue what he
should do he doesn't have a mentor so
that peace that's normally assumed to be
present in any design story design is
just lifted out and it leaves a gap in
there that's absolutely horrifying it's
it's a horrible thing to realize you're
on your own man there's nobody who can
advise you how to deal with this
situation or if they're there they're
Hollow they're useless they don't really
serve so it's up to you and that's quite
quite chilling and horrifying they found
a wonderful beautiful way to do it but
it was a kind of psychological horror
story so uh and that's refreshing uh
because it makes you look at the whole
design in a different way like I've
assumed there must be this and this and
this what if this and this are not there
uh is that still a story uh might be and
it might be a very interesting story uh
that that is missing some pieces or
pieces are repeated sometimes that
um the economical Mind of a Hollywood
producer would say why do we have two of
those but the poetic mind says well
because it's nice to get Reflections and
to see two different characters
having the same problem and dealing with
it in slightly different ways uh that
that's uh you know an interesting
pattern that sort of breaks the formula
but does it in an interesting way
so it sounds like there were 11 then
stages but the mentor stage was taken
out of that movie and it still worked
yeah the the movie the the movie I was
referring to uh more
um still worked very well
um and I think one interpretation of it
is that the man looked outwardly for
mentors which is where you would
normally look
but in fact realized the only Mentor is
on board right here I'm it and so I'm
going to have to do something about this
situation and he does something rather
drastic
um and very dramatic and kind of scary
but uh in his universe that was the
right thing to do so uh yeah I I think
that's uh
a way of getting off of this idea of
things being a formula I I think if you
set out to take the 12 stages as I've
described them and create a story that
hit every one of those beats you would
actually end up with a kind of a boring
trite story where people would know what
was coming because we have seen so many
examples and what we're really watching
for when we
enjoy a movie is the places where they
broke the pattern where it was it went
off and where I don't know what's
happening that I don't know why it's
happening I don't know who that is I
don't know what archetype that character
represents then I'm thrilled and I'm a
child again I go back to that childlike
State of Mind of of Wonder like what is
that just like when I was originally
read the fairy tales by my mother and
grandmother and they'd throw something
in like a giant or a A Fairy Godmother
I'd go what is that because I'd never
encountered it before so sometimes these
uh interruptions of the pattern are the
things that make it really beautiful
but that being said if someone does want
to try something different
it may be a glaring hole you may be like
well there's number three and number
eight missing and that's why it's not
working so it's kind of there's a pros
and cons there's maybe two formulaic or
stuff is not uh there's holes there's
gaps well you know there's this idea
that that a story sometimes have holes
in them that you can drive a truck
through we like to say that when we're
criticizing stories
um
but that's not always a bad thing
sometimes it's an accident of editing
that we didn't we've shot that scene
that explained that but we had to cut it
out for time or or some other uh you
know the the it rained that day and we
couldn't use the footage or something
didn't match
um but that can create again this very
interesting tension in the design and uh
you know uh can bring that sense of
wonder back to it I I have one example
that I I like to point out is I like
Hitchcock because he's playing in this
very playful way of Mastery with uh all
these things with fairy tale spooky
things scary things Shadows and Light
um but he will often deliberately leave
a gap in his explanation of things like
in one of his movies notorious Cary
Grant is a spymaster who's trying to get
Ingrid Bergman to help him to seduce
some Nazi spies and get their secrets
and
um you know there's something weird
about Cary Grant in the way that he
deals with women and the uh wonderful
love that she's offering to him she was
pleading with him please forget about
the spy stuff let's run away and uh you
know we're obviously meant for each
other so why don't we just skip all this
dangerous spy stuff and he sticks to his
duty but he's unusually weird about
romantic things about kissing and uh all
all the stuff that you would think would
be automatic for Cary Grant
and Hitchcock just refuses to tell you
why that is so it invites me as an
audience member to fill in that blank
and the missing piece that I've filled
in is that Cary Grant was a spy during
World War II and he had a lover who was
also a spy and she betrayed him and he
had to kill her and that's not in the
script but it's very attractive uh
solution for me for this mystery that
Hitchcock allows to just dangle there he
doesn't uh draw attention to it nor does
he uh spend any time explaining it but
uh it it added to my delight and my
pleasure in the film now that film is
mine because I wrote part of it you know
and I think the audience enjoys
sometimes when there is a disjuncture in
the story or there's a missing piece
they get a big kick out of filling it in
and imagining that for themselves this
is the whole world of fan fiction which
is a wonderful development that people
love the story so much that they'll
write in these kind of explanations and
backstories that the original creators
didn't provide